into this week's Android developer
office hours live from London today
we're joined by Chris pains Mac on Nick
butcher and le pas from the Google Play
Developer console team at least joining
us today which is like a couple of
announcements she's going to make it the
top of the show ah as normal anna says
not be making any announcements but we
will be making you an answer might be
talking about road maps or any other
these products we have a pretty full
moderator today so it's going to go
quite quickly to get through them all
I'm going to try and make a note of one
with answer these questions so
afterwards I can put a little so not
just under the YouTube video make that
even more useful yeah so welcome to the
guy's a live in the Hangout as well
we've got what you want to say hi I'm
too far away so she students they could
I hey everybody Weaver and you'll see I
recognize over there and we got people
piling in it so on welcome to everyone
in the Hangout as Giuseppe as my car six
a chance to ask some questions shortly
Bethany yummy it will hopefully have
some information on the new Play
Developer console 40 so we've had a lot
of like I guess a lot of interest in the
new developer console a lot of people
are using it already which is great and
last weekly to ask people you know what
what are things that you'd be looking
for that would encourage you to use in
your developer console and so today we
actually released a number of new
different features and most of them
haven't been announced or four so I
guess you're the first people to find
out so the Google Play private channel
is now available in the new developer
console so if your company or
organization is using google apps to
distribute do we have a happy guy down
there I saw some oh hey so if that was
keeping you from switching to the new
developer console you can now use that
to take certain applications and
distribute them only within your Google
Apps domain so go ahead and use that
right now you can find it on the pricing
and distribution page if you just scroll
all the way to the bottom the second
thing is that the announcements module
is now in the new developer console so
you'll be able to get any news and other
a piece of information that we're
sharing there you can find that in the
left side of the navigation it looks
kind of like a megaphone and it lights
up bright orange when there's a new
announcement they're so you can try
clicking on it and seeing what's in
there the next thing that we have is a
sort of a detail but many people when
they get in there string resources they
don't know which language codes
correlate with which language names so
we're now showing the knee the the
language name and also the language code
together so that if someone sending you
a big file and it's specified only by
the language code you can be completely
sure that you're putting it into the
right language so that's sort of a
detail and the next thing probably I
think the most popular change is a lot
of people been asking how do i delete a
draft application maybe you could
created an application oops it was the
wrong package name you switched or you
just had some experiments that you
decided not to publish so that is now
available you can find that in the upper
right hand corner of your developer
console and if you look in the little
menu where it'll say draft you can click
on that there should be an option under
there that says delete this application
also need almost sorry off Jeeves on
that would you go to reuse the package
name again is it gone ah I think so I'm
not a hundred percent sure about that
usually when people I mean there's no
reason why you would want to do that if
you have used the package name you
should just carry on with that one but
it's more like a few a lot of people
won't create the wrong package name and
realize need to change it so if you
already have that package name in there
it's fine you don't do anything but if
you sort of clutter up your developer
console now you can declutter it from
apps that have never been published
right once you publish an application
even if you unpublish it you can't
delete it but if it's a draft and it's
never been published you can delete it
just want I said I tested the future
yeah minutes ago yeah did it work yeah
fantastic okay I'm very glad that you
mess it up for us you know the feature
is there you see no I um I tried to I
have to develop her accounts no one is
for legacy because the Israeli market
was changed to the Israel currency so I
had to open a new developer account and
when I tried to enter the to log in with
the legacy one he said it was I had a
message saying i need to pay $25 again
to registered developer so I chain so I
already so I paid again and when I
entered to the developer console saw all
the new features also the megaphone and
also the strings and everything cool we
updated the developer console just a
couple of hours ago yeah so I was lucky
to see all the changes a real real time
cool is how relevantly show is exactly I
was right there did you think it was a
dream that you saw a megaphone that
wasn't there before confirm it here and
then the other thing that we've that
we've launched today is what we're
calling the statistics annotations so a
lot of times when you're looking at your
statistics craft wonder why did that go
up I had a certain number of users and
then it went up or I had a rating and
then it just dipped all of a sudden and
a lot of times that's because you've
released a new version maybe that new
version has different functionality
maybe you fix some bugs and that caused
your rating to go up and so now we have
little dots on your statistics page that
show when each of your different APK
versions went out so you can just hover
your mouse over your statistics page on
this little grey dot that comes up and
it will say okay that was the version
number seven or that was version number
50 and you can use that to see if some
of the spikes in your statistics graph
are correlated with new releases based
based on your efficient code or version
name uh I don't I think I don't remember
which one it shows it definitely shows
either one of the two um every APK has
both a virgin code and a version number
I don't remember which one it shows I
think it might well I'm not even gonna
guess cuz I don't you check rieber and
send us yeah you can check and tell us
you can go tom check cool yeah it only
works on an application where you've
released multiple versions
it so after you've released your second
version you'll have some great dots on
there yeah basically all we have for
today that's all of our new features but
I hope the message to any developers out
there listening is you know keep using
the new developer console click the
feedback link let us know what you think
and we have a team here in London that's
working to make more improvement so even
if you're looking for something that
isn't there yet you know it still could
come out pretty soon so just keep
telling us what you think and we'll keep
working on it absolutely if there's any
reason why you haven't switched from the
old developer console to the new one
just let us know on google+ straightaway
yeah we definitely like to hear those
comments and if you're having any
problems who want to make sure that the
support team figures them out for you so
the new design console is first be
all-encompassing yes just to let
everyone know the version code is what I
see is a grating a dot on the graph so
it's version code thank you excellent
are you gonna make a note well that's it
for this week's Android developer office
hours up let's go and play with a new
console it's gonna be half an hour for
control these little things okay um
before we fire up into my writer has
anybody probably hang out that I
question I was a few things down in the
chat window I'm just blown here the
Texas we couldn't read it are we saw
someone saying you because if it should
the version name as well as the version
code okay I'll take that note literally
melted it was all staring at the screens
we get better glasses everyone same
festival asian name interesting all
right then Plus Ones nope yep oh thank
you lady oh you heard it here first and
use briefly thick around are you guys
good to simply wish to greg was a
question in the moderator oh well we'll
see you some English most commercial go
stretch to that one go on then we'll go
straight to the more inertia which from
you say she hasn't met Topher is it
written about her future roadmap when
will use while hans peter has said when
will you start publishing regional
android version distribution of us in
addition to the global I've oh wow this
is a nice to the developer console
agassi I feel this was the person asking
to be able to do my regional
yes is it like a version of Android this
is why we only publish surgery has the
most ice cream some reg let's not stand
looking for dinner and yeah that's
something we won't talk about yeah yeah
no information but if you look at some
like dis tomos it some days done man
yeah this team I that's it they put out
some interesting stats or let's go in
stats counter GS does technology that's
the best way to get information is to
publish a nap on the face door yes that
she get access to everything that
publish it and make it successful in
every country of the world find out all
this uneasy or have a button that all
over the world and see ya oh look out
for something I don't like Oh a penny
and people like that they might they
have some interesting stats that are
terrible okay other questions for having
what else have you got in there one
right it becomes get everybody's looking
at you so sweet Andrew Kelly and Chris
each yeah yeah yeah we had a camera when
he jumped in but then he muted it back
from white on the father time to Kelly
as access to her he's implementing a new
filter for the array data and it seems
to be particularly cumbersome because of
mostly in tunnels are private he
switched I sit up there but does he do
have any tips do I have any tips for
using the right up tough to live um not
really as such it shouldn't be much
different to use the right actors it
would be abated up by the end
differences you won't have direct access
to the sort of collection but you can
use you can just iterate so as you
normally would or use in get size and
get item just it's right through there
should be much different I couldn't
think of it pump in your way where would
tell you you want to chime in
he might change this idea I carry on
I'll measure up with the G+ stream
moments in time so yeah I can't even get
much soft difficult good okay vixen
might snap um we've seen anything that
you don't scare for impressions so
someone's asking one will subscriptions
come to in-app billing version 2 which
is the also which is last week version 3
well yeah its roots oh yeah yeah from V
to interview for a year yeah just like
the new developer console is balling
promising the in-app billing v3 is now
also ornamenting there's no reason you
should be using v2 v2 v3 is better
everything away lot easier for you till
you may as well so there's lot fewer
gotchas and pink ear to ear way up so
yeah let you see one cup chef david i-i
mean up there's no more money titans yep
correct its rates whether all but it's a
blessing and a curse yeah mostly bliss
yeah so if you have an unmanaged item
now you have to consume the item that
you actually i should use it so i sort
of couple of partners hmm ask me how to
consumer items well they didn't know how
they had to be yes which to me three
without reading the docs very
interesting yes that's about the only
one another than that it should be about
you oh I'm saying is there an ETA for
in-app billing version for this is Rufus
or else okay it was a virgin of this
mixed up ok karma Chris all I'm on a
part you've got this one ok and I'll
take one from the floor if anybody in
the Hangout has a question get ready for
it num I possibly is on Google+ as well
is there a good alternative for the left
menu bar on a Google TV there's a lot of
complaints in that isn't the right
navigation fuel for a good for a TV yeah
so there's no real good solution I think
all we see
a lot of developers do especially when
you look at someone like amazon etc like
they start just going down the route of
making quite a custom UI in terms of
what makes sense of their content I
think the general thing that we're
trying to encourage developers to do is
only show the relevant information based
on where the use of focusing kind of try
and keep the UI as clean and as basic
and kind of as attractive as possible
and then start showing them additional
information depending on where they're
focusing because that's going to be the
main way to interact so yeah I don't
have a perfect solution to kind of avoid
using left nav bar the biggest thing is
to try and avoid that navigation trap
when you're using the action bar because
you're using up and down along with the
list view etc it's going to run into
problems yeah fine we don't have a
perfect solution I have played with some
of the slide in the drawers they do work
on Google TV we started playing around
with the idea of having the menu button
to kind of slide it open and close it
which is an okay design paradigm but
obviously you have to kind of train the
easy to do it and then you start running
into issues of is that the right thing
or not and it kind of starts going
against I think the way you'd use it on
tablets lower those cuz then well the
default thing is you can actually make
it so that when you focus to the left
and then you get to the point beyond the
edge of screen it'll open it for you and
then when you focus out it will close it
for you so that's in the public user
menu button to open is it in focuses
yeah you can be like because you're
programatically Dave but yeah this
exponent issues we were playing with you
can do it that way but I'm not entirely
convinced it's a great kind of user
experience so that those are kind of the
main things that I've seen people trying
to do but I don't have a perfect
solution not one I'd say definitely go
down this route yeah okay Shane I know
right I'll ask other answer and
expression so Andy has asked how secure
is data stored in sort of shared
preferences when using both private
necessities it worth doing
so mode private icicle II it makes the
firewalls only accessible to your user I
did there's no so if there are other
apps that are sharing your user ID that
can access those files if the device is
rooted sort of the you sort of a rooted
app could actually access as fast too so
it depends on the context of the
information that you're storing but sort
of it's up to you really and if you're
talking about encryption then you get
down to then we're gonna saw the key yep
when I say you might just end up moving
the problem rather than solving the
problem and there's some great
guidelines published yesterday by Trevor
Jones on the Android developers blog
which say don't create and store the key
beforehand make sure you create it on
the device after runtime and then store
it so that if someone does get older the
kids it doesn't apply to in every single
instance of your education and then it
says saw the the salt for the key arcing
local and then that is relying on your
user ID to protect it and then
regenerate the key when you need it use
secure remnant month a few other things
these put it in there so there's a blog
post of kearney on android developers
blog blogspot yeah obviously these are
all defeated if you if users have rooted
their devices so I'd say yeah it comes
out it's like your banking information
or something like that then probably
don't store it on the device like a
anything super secure like you know it's
not a trusted computing platform the
other day you know people have access to
information saying yeah and it's the
information what is secure these days ah
secure um store the hashes or whatever
you need to access your service on the
device in unsecured claim sex passwords
are coated or Hospital reverse engineer
aboard oceans of class a bit that would
be crazy we've got a few people asking
about i obv to bugs we do know there was
a lot of issues with i obv to messages
were bundled up a lot of developers
wouldn't read them all it was very hard
to debug a lot of the IAB v2 issues so
obviously they are the answer is if
you're having I abv two issues please
please please switch to IAB be three
that's what it's there for and seeker is
asking something in the chat window can
we aren't in questions in check yes we
can ah in the follow-up question at the
bottom from seeker is it possible
to clear programmatically google chrome
cash on Android I think not you can send
someone to the app info for chrome and
they can choose to press the clear cache
button but I don't believe that you
could and that no no no you can turn to
the app info they can clear the cache in
the data there but you can't from your
application go ahead and start clearing
other applications data it would also be
against the developer distribution
agreement which says you're not allowed
to interfere with the behavior of other
applications something also inside by
josef these last two questions about the
developer console he asks he would like
contact information for crashes for the
user who include a crash she's
interesting to enforce supports and so
thanks for that suggestion and number
two he says when when will we get reply
to review now this is a really common
question I guess what you know what
we're doing right now is we're rolling
it out gradually to more developers over
time and you know sorry that you don't
have it yet we have been making some
tweaks the feature as we do roll it out
so hopefully by the time we do get it
out more it'll be a better experience
for both developers and users so please
hold tight sorry about the delays ok
back in the moderator Nick in Chicago it
asks he says he has a jail view on top
of two video views which he switches to
go from an intro video to a looping
video and in between you get a black
screen flash which is a the background
actually bleeding through and has Mecca
gutless and chris is posted a link to
stack overflow post which is very very
good but just to add a little bit of
context of that so a surfaceview is
actually a hole in your view hierarchy
and the reason we do this is because
normally has many videos and in order to
not have to re composite the whole thing
we're trying to get it to the window
it's much more efficient to render it
like this so it takes one less copy and
you can play videos much I framer and so
on and so forth and but yeah the
consequence of that is that it's not a
view hierarchy so you get these strange
things where something might bleed
through from having this hole in it so
yeah you can't actually get around the
whole black flash you know kind of avoid
it happening but what you can is work
around it so you can put something on
top of it so you can put like a view on
top of your and
and you serve this view right and so
during the transition you might put you
know fade to black a view on top switch
out the video view underneath and then
fade that view back out to transparency
to give the impression of a gapless
playback so it's just a consequence of
using that and the alternative is you
could take a look at text review which
is available since my ice cream sandwich
so API Levin and not supporting sorry
okay and but that does involve an extra
memory memory copy so you might want to
not use that for your entire video
playback or tested see other
performances nailed it Oh someone's just
destroy a trap hopefully if you had a
question in the chat was rushed things
me to do reverb about you why don't
support but the ID weeks there's no be
oh yeah they work very well for android
development and some people do user
IntelliJ for that Android coming but
yeah the primary folks at the tools team
there they have to focus on something at
the moment focused on upland
interestings coming from Ron in israel
says just joined us live yeah i say that
house you and I ask your question live
run obviously not it's not even think he
is and if you're muted can you unmute no
why no it's not near enough on the
Hangout okay anyway well if you if you
manage to make noise then you can try
them in Iran but until then I'll crack
on with what you've written in the
moderators you asked it like to load an
eyepatch image from a remote server so
you write worship exactly you die
yeah yeah you want to ask your life pay
for it yeah sure we all know that
usually we we have image views that get
to get their images remotely and I want
to try and do that with with an eye
patch image basically so in order to do
that
I've dig a lot in resources resource
type dot age and do nine packed and all
that and I understood that I either need
to compile the dot light dot PNG on the
server side before I hand it down to my
end to my application I couldn't found
finding the utility that will do that
and there is some way to hack apt to do
that but it was something that I can
rely on in the production environment
and so I've looked through another way
in depth to basically compile the
deadline dot PNG file in real time on
the fly in my application which means
dripping down and the extra two pixels
on each dimension and create the new P&G
file and the chance a battery and then
then use the nine patch durable
interface or API basically and to create
an iPad chain programmatically I am
ashamed to say that I failed to success
like I couldn't do that I mean I've
tried for about a week and I couldn't
find any resource on the next to do that
or any other leading here so any help
will be greatly appreciated yeah I mean
that there is no supported by doing this
were like no fishy spoiled right and it
doesn't has been documented there's a
question similar to miss Louise on the
show and I was a couple of stack
overflow Fred's which willing so someone
has worked out I remember the exact
details but there's like a quiter I that
you can sort of decode the resource wave
they will actually do for you but I
can't remember off the top my head i'll
also look and good reply later and so
yeah I love a look into sort of apply
after this show you know we have heard
this question before yeah I have passed
around the Android team I remember you
as well and the resounding response has
been that there isn't a way of doing it
for a nice to supported way of doing it
it would but why not do the egg yeah to
take care of all the files on the server
yeah neutralize your then at the whim of
network compression or icon stuff so if
the network mangled your file in between
I could have less so if you're on a
mobile network most mobile networks
compress images I i can press your line
patch and you'll it won't work anymore
yeah so just do a secure way to transfer
the files in parts like a multi-part
encoded in base64 maybe so I'm how to to
bypass the mobile networking compression
please I'm everything is secured a and
tunnel so the and the mobile day the
mobile operator doesn't know what I'm
passing there but they have no way to to
touch my data I know that because in
Israel we have a mobile operator that if
you try to do speak hey salaam and leave
everything below as powerful as for the
transporter will beat pls based though
novella curtain won't touch my data so i
know that i'll i'll get the mg file
exact leds on this book okay yeah just
looking at the time we danced the last
five minutes of today's hangout so well
maybe have a quick look at the next page
and good the photo writer but has
anybody got anything urgent they want to
get in before the end of the hang out
anymore questions from inside the chat
for the Hangout as we just put through
the last couple of questions magic is
asked by google air tickets by one um
okay so swords asking is 0 design
pattern for synchronizing rows of data
between disparate systems doing
different devices in particular without
having conflicting key identifier
because they're using uuid but I think
there will not work for a large system
any comments interesting so there's a
bunch of different things you do so I
don't know how you're actually
synchronizing Isis I don't know if
you're using some kind of like back-end
system like a pending or whether you can
feel something like this like we gave a
workshop on how to use google drive for
example to synchronize data between the
two devices i know dropbox just launched
a similar api for android to help you to
do sinking a bit of data between devices
but when you're talking about the actual
key creation so like if you're creating
a object on two devices and you want
them to not collide then yeah it makes
sense to either you some kind of good
well I think the way dr actually does it
is he doesn't have an identifying to try
and upload it and when you upload it
drive will give you an identifier so you
hear something like that perhaps if I've
understood the correction the question
yeah you can generate something bigger
it right random with a timestamp seen it
will be completely unique okay somebody
else who's that in the chat in the in
the Hangout there think okay nothing say
um yeah unless anybody else does it oh
hi hi yeah going that well as your enemy
she'll go ahead just speak slowly
because the get after I am trying to
have a schedule is the proper way in
addition that his point in topography p
the data thunder
from the on the call let me go to clean
the back their cache of google chrome
the application yeah if you could
question into the chat window were
having a bit of trouble hearing hearing
what you're saying oh he knows any
writing guys they just did it was the
question about the cash for chrome okay
yeah we answered that that it was
impossible um personally if I was
looking for that I would got the device
in go to the app info and see which
intent was fired to get trap info and I
put that intent in some application so
when you fire it off the user gets taken
to Chrome's app info crime probably
supports the intent for going directly
to our storage settings as well as
proven of documented say it could change
yeah I must rest upon our loop right
okay so the finger that brings us the
end of our time this week so thank you
everyone who's crease submitted the
questions i hope you enjoying the new
shorter format if we get through quite a
lot of content and it's easier for you
to read watch later as well and so as
always we prefer questions pre submitted
in advance into the moderator queue so
if you have any questions or we didn't
get rancho question please do submit it
to the next week and thanks to everyone
who joined us live and for joining in
and asking great questions in the
sidebar or live and we will see you
again same time next time so no woke up
we got here all right now it's guys
thank you everyone thanks for a bunch
all the new one everyone loved the gum